à notre second thème tout de suite vous
savez on choisit volontairement décalé
de de l'actualité du jour alors il va
tourner autour d'un d'un chiffre ce soir
7 millions 380000 spectateurs dans les
salles de cinéma au mois de septembre
c'est le plus bas niveau de
fréquentation enregistrée depuis
1980 le cinéma français est-il en danger
comment lui redonner toute sa vitalité
ce qui fait voilà notre plaisir de de
spectateur et la fierté de ceux qui le
fabrique on commence avant d'en débattre
par le constat détaillé par Pierre Henry
holderbaum
certains prennent le temps de s'arrêter
d'autres passent devant sans même un
regard un constat observé par le Centre
national du cinéma qui enregistre en
septembre une baisse de plus de 30% par
rapport à septembre 2019
devant les salles la première raison
c'est le prix il y a des bons plans pour
les étudiants mais ça reste encore peu
accessibles je trouve pour oui quand on
a pas de réduction je trouve que c'est
hyper cher par exemple l'autre jour j'ai
voulu y aller et j'étais avec des un
copains et je me dis bah vas-y je te
prends ta place et on y va et là je vois
le panier je l'ai pris sur internet ça
va être 30 euros tu vois déjà pour deux
places tu es un petit peu mal
dans ce cinéma parisien le Brady la
baisse de fréquentation est moins
importante mais elle est tout de même
observée les chiffres sont un petit peu
traumatisants et nous ils ont commencé à
baisser dès le mois de juillet et donc
comme on peut le remarquer sur sur ce
graphique on est en perte d'entrée on
était à moins 23 75% sur sur le mois de
septembre si certaines places atteignent
les 14 euros ici de 9 euros le prix
n'est donc pas la seule raison pour
cette exploitant la fin de covid
c'est-à-dire que il y a un moment où
quand les gens pendant plusieurs mois
ont pris de mauvaises habitudes
et plutôt plutôt orienté sur sur une
pratique casanière de de la proposition
cinématographique bah il faut le
redonner le goût de venir au cinéma des
multiples facteurs sont pointés du doigt
les plateformes de streaming ou encore
le cinéma d'auteur qui ne correspondrait
pas aux attentes du spectateur quand
vous y allez ponctuellement ça ça a
toujours été le cas vous voulez plutôt
du grand spectacle vous voulez quand
même plutôt quelque chose qui vous
ébouriffe
effectivement est-ce que le cinéma
français un cinéma plutôt d’auteur peut
attirer un grand public avec des places
à 12 euros et encore une fois je pense
que il y a très peu de place qui
atteignent cette fourchette haute ben
rien que rien qu'en ce moment on est
contredit par cette par cette idée
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un film qui
semble être fait pour le grand public et
celui-ci n'y va pas et puis un film dont
on se dit qu'il va réunir peu de gens et
qui finalement arrive quand même à
exister après à se frayer un chemin
alors les chemins aujourd'hui sont à 200
300.000 sont des succès maintenant
entrer là où autrefois c'est un million
pour faire revenir le public des
enseignes proposent de nouvelles
expériences en utilisant des
technologies comme la kdx des écrans
panoramiques à 270 degrés ou des sièges
qui bougent pendant des scènes il y a
aussi beaucoup de cinéma qui ne vont pas
aller dans cette direction et l'idée
n'est pas d'être dans l'assurant cher
permanente c'est aussi ton offre des
films qui vont être proposés et dans la
communication qu'on va faire autour ce
qui est important c'est de
c'est de rappeler au spectateur la
plus-value de voir un film en salle en
terme d'expérience on pourrait réfléchir
d'une façon plus globale à la place du
cinéma par exemple on réfléchissant à ce
qu'on a fait pour le livre on a mis en
place il y a quelques années un principe
de prix unique pour le livre ça pourrait
être intéressant de réfléchir à ça pour
le cinéma les cinémas français ont
également été fragilisés cette année par
le peu de sortie de blockbusters
américains en raison des arrêts de
tournage pendant la période de covid
voilà le prix des places la concurrence
des plateformes l'offre de films
évidemment tous ces thèmes on valait les
détailler tout de suite avec mes invités
Fanny Héraud bonsoir vous êtes
scénariste vous avez notamment participé
à la création de la série 10% je ne cite
que celle-là mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui mettent auditino bonsoir
vous êtes un chef de la rubrique cinéma
à Télérama Philippe Carcassonne bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
producteur là aussi je vais pas pouvoir
s'y fit citer tous les films il y a de
father de Florian Zeller police de
Maïwenn ou alors le le Maigret de
Patrice Leconte le très réussi Maigret
de Patrice fontaine police de Maïwenn a
été produit par l'intage
c'est mon erreur ça m'arrive une fois de
temps en temps le bug de démarrage
désolé pour cette erreur et Laetitia
cruppa surtout annefontaine c'était
c'était un gros un gros bug de ma part
Laetitia Crépin est toujours à mes côtés
bref mais à coule pas 7 euros 04 c'est
le prix moyen d'une place de cinéma en
2021 + 6,2% par rapport à 2020
quand on peut voir potentiellement des
centaines de films en payant 9 euros
l'abonnement à Netflix est-ce que c'est
l'une des explications peut-être la
première explication selon vous
non je pense pas parce que il y a quatre
ou cinq ans on n'était pas forcément au
même moment de la crise et pourtant les
gens aller au cinéma davantage donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans les trois
quatre dernières années c'est pas que ça
peut-être que ça joue un peu mais c'est
pas que le prix je pense c'est toutes
sortes d'habitude c'est le covid qui est
passé par là c'est c'est nos vies qui
changent en fait c'est effectivement la
profusion des images dans nos vies c'est
pas qu'une histoire de prix je crois
Philippe Carcassonne c'est vrai que
c'est réducteur de de ramener ça au prix
mon on est dans un contexte de de
rentrer social difficile de pouvoir
d'achat il y a beaucoup de Français qui
sont à l'euro près aujourd'hui donc on
sait que c'est dépenses là les dépenses
de loisirs sont souvent les premières
les premières impactés donc ça c'est
peut-être une explication conjoncturelle
il y en a des beaucoup plus
structurelles pour vous
je pense que le prix joue quand même
beaucoup
le CNC a publié en mai 2022 une étude
qui listait les raisons de la
désaffection du public et le prix
arriver
assez haut dans la hiérarchie des
raisons je m'empresse de dire que la
même étude
ne faisait apparaître qu'en cinquième
position
le présumé manque d'attractivité des
films donc on peut certainement
s'interroger sur la tractivité de nos
films on le fait par définition dans nos
métiers vous moi tout le monde mais il y
a au moins quatre raisons avant sur
lesquels se pencher
10 m odyssino je disais 7 euros 7 euros
04 on l'a vu dans le reportage ça peut
monter beaucoup plus haut déjà dans les
grandes villes notamment à Paris en
fonction de enfin voilà s'il y a de la
3D s'il y a des sièges effectivement 4Dx
etc etc je vais pas faire toute la liste
des des propositions ça peut flirter
avec les 14 les 15 euros dans le
reportage il y avait une évocation d'un
prix unique est-ce que ça pourrait être
plus simple finalement pour les pour
nous pour nous spectateurs est-ce que
vous y croyez à ça je sais pas vraiment
si j'y crois je crois au Cardone
abonnement ça j'ai la mienne ça marche
très bien
ce qui s'est passé particulièrement
pendant la pandémie c'est que les gens
ont rendu leur carte les gens ont rendu
leur abonnement il y a eu un je sais
plus quel est évidemment la statistique
je l'ai oublié mais il y a eu vraiment
un pourcentage important d'abonnés de
Cavé qui était abonné dans différents ou
multiplex ou cinéma de quartier dans des
associations l'afkae cinéma les cinémas
labellisé indépendant d'arrêter ils ont
rendu leur carte parce qu'évidemment ils
allaient plus au cinéma mais ils n'ont
pas repris leur abonnement donc en fait
moi je pense d'abord le premier appel à
faire parce que ça c'est financier c'est
mais reprenez vos cartes d'abonnement
donc il y a un déficit de communication
mais oui je pense que vraiment ne
serait-ce que ça refaire de la pub pour
qu'il reprenne leur carte d'abonnement
puisque on n'arrête pas dans d'opposer
cinéma en salle et les abonnements
là-bas là sur les plateformes
abonnez-vous au cinéma réabonnez-vous et
après par mois et donc en trois films on
l'a la rentabilité quoi absolument et
pour ce qui est des prix des places
je pense que ça dépend parce que même
des gens qui vont trouver chers le
cinéma vont quand même soudainement à
les mettre et là c'est même pas 9 euros
mais 18 euros dans un énorme bloc de
Buster où il faut aussi payer les
lunettes en 3D le fauteuil qui bascule
et tout le truc qui va avec donc c'est
une question de désir c'est une question
de relancer le désir voilà pas forcément
que de porte-monnaie alors Philippe
Carcassonne vous avez appelé comme
beaucoup d'autres professionnels à
l'organisation d'État généraux du cinéma
français faisant l'espérer quoi une
sorte de remise à plat de réflexion
commune
pardon j'essaie d'être court mais il
faut un petit peu
on a le temps
nous avons une tutelle dédiée qui
s'appelle le Centre national du cinéma
et de l'image animée le CNC et nous
avons des organisations professionnelles
pour chaque secteur qui sont très actifs
je crois qu'on a vu Rosalie brun la SRF
pour le réalisateur en complément de
l'art il y a trois syndicats de
producteurs il y en a trois
distributeurs etc etc ces organisations
travaillent quotidiennement avec le CNC
et nous défendent secteur par secteur et
essaie de se battre pour maintenir les
acquis comme on dit dans le vocabulaire
du lutte social même si c'est un peu
déplacé ici
mais ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas effectivement fait une
mise à plat et qu'on sait pas interrogé
sur
les fondements de la politique
culturelle on a très longtemps vécu avec
l'idée que l'exception culturelle à la
française c'est-à-dire un encadrement au
sens presque physique du terme du
secteur nous permettrait de traverser
des crises il se trouve que celle-ci qui
est une double crise c'est à dire à la
fois un avènement beaucoup plus rapide
que prévu des plateformes et la crise
sanitaire qui accéléré le premier volet
nous a complètement pris au dépourvu au
sens où nous n'avons absolument pas eu
le temps de nous organiser comme on l'a
été à l'arrivée des télépéantes à
l'arrivée à cassette du DVD de ce que
vous voudrez enfin des mutations il y a
eu d'autres crises et vous aviez entre
guillemets su les anticiper on a on
avait les éléments pour l'anticiper et
les pouvoirs publics nous ont
accompagné prépare la main et adapter la
réglementation à cette mutation là il y
a un certain nombre de facteurs qui font
que la crise est enfin la mutation
parlons même pas de crise mais la
mutation que tout le monde voit comme
inévitable elle arrive beaucoup plus
vite que prévu dans un contexte de crise
globale sur le laquelle vous êtes mieux
renseigné avec moi mais enfin pas besoin
d'être un génie pour voir que c'est un
peu compliqué sur d'autres fronts et à
l'époque les gouvernements de droite
comme de gauche d'ailleurs avait quand
même été très déterminé très
volontariste dans leur politique de
protection de l'exception culturelle il
y a quelques éléments même si je
m'empresse de le dire je n'ai pas en
cause la tutelle du CNC je pense que le
CNC a plein de bonnes intentions et
plein de bonnes volonté en tout cas je
le crois mais
le CNC ne fait pas l'appui et le beau
temps en matière de politique culturelle
appliquée au cinéma donc ils nous tous
selon développement pour vous dire
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui
le contexte nous a paru mur a beaucoup
d'entre nous y compris ceux qui sont
représentés c'est mon cas par des
syndicats de dire il nous faut une
concentration transversale non plus avec
le CNC mais plutôt avec l'État ça
implique le mystère de la culture le
ministère des Finances qui pèse très
lourdement sur notre secteur Premier
ministre il disait enfin qui vous ont
pour en parler paisiblement alors
justement Laetitia vous êtes allés à la
recherche de de la ministre de la
Culture rimable plutôt discrète on va
dire depuis sa nomination oui l'ex
conseiller culture d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'Élysée et carrément en dessous de tous
les radars médiatiques et donc forcément
une audible alors j'ai tenté de recenser
ces interviews depuis la rentrée dans
l'audiovisuel je précise parce que c'est
quand même la rampe de lancement la plus
favorable quand on cherche de la
notoriété j'en ai trouvé quelques-unes
dont une sur France Culture où elle a
été interrogée justement sur la
politique culturelle qu'elle était
chargée
censé mettre en oeuvre écouter la
réponse de la ministre
pour moi c'est une vision qui est à la
fois ancrée dans l'histoire et tournée
vers l'avenir c'est une vision qui fait
dialoguer le patrimoine et la création
et qui pensent la souveraineté
culturelle de la France je m'explique
pour Emmanuel Macron et je partage
complètement cette vision la voix de la
France dans ce monde numérique qui
s'accélère de plus en plus et qui se
bouleverse incessamment comment la
porter comment la faire vivre comment la
faire exister bon je sais pas vous mais
pour moi ça reste quand même un peu flou
langage plutôt des narcs on va dire
alors j'ai continué mon enquête pas bien
loin je vais être honnête sur Twitter
j'ai vu qu'elle avait participé je ne
sais pas si vous y étiez le mois dernier
à Deauville a une journée de débat
justement sur les enjeux du cinéma avec
les exploitants mais on en a pas
beaucoup entendu parler quels sont par
exemple les conclusions de cette journée
de réflexion elle a aussi manifesté son
soutien avec un petit peu une méthode
Coué on va dire en retouitant un tweet
d'un journaliste de cinéma d'un écrivain
le cinéma français va très bien c'est un
peu le message qu'elle voulait faire
passer avec plusieurs affiches de films
à voir et puis outre son hommage à
Jean-Louis Godard bon bah ça s'arrête là
Thomas mais en même temps il y a une
actualité on l'a évoqué sociale
international qui est tellement dense
que la culture passe un peu après
évidemment les médias ne se bousculent
pas pour inviter Rima Abdul Malak comme
ils ne se sont pas bousculés pendant
l'élection présidentielle pour mettre la
culture dans les débats presque aucune
question n'a été posée sur la culture
aux candidats à la présidentielle et
bien sûr en toile de fond il y a quand
même en cette rentrée imprécisément et
en contraste et en miroir de la crise
que vivent tous les Français la crise du
pouvoir d'achat l'aide massive qui a
apporté l'État au secteur pendant la
période du covid et puis aussi l'aquit
du précédent quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron les 300 000 millions qui sont
promis au financement du cinéma français
qui provien des plateformes donc ça peut
expliquer d'une certaine manière que le
cinéma ne soit pas au coeur et vous le
déplorez je le comprends du débat
politique alors on y reviendra
évidemment sur le le rôle des des
plateformes la concurrence des des
plateformes j'entendais il y a quelques
jours sur France Inter la réalisatrice
Nicole Garcia qui disait que le cinéma
français n'était pas assez protégé par
le CNC et par le ministère de la de la
culture
comment ça vous fait réagir ça est-ce
qu'elle a pas la mémoire un peu courte
vous allez citer le l'apport des
plateformes il y a eu aussi les aides de
l'État pendant le covid 343 millions
d'euros pour compenser la fermeture des
salles 50 millions d'euros pour un fond
destiné au tournage où serait le cinéma
français s'il y avait pas eu l'État
depuis deux ans on peut aussi dire ça
vous voyez
j'ai l'impression que la crise covid
c'est un temps particulier en fait c'est
un temps de crise donc par définition ça
nécessite des mesures un peu
exceptionnelles mais là ce dont on parle
je crois là aujourd'hui c'est en dehors
de ça c'est à dire c'est beaucoup plus
structurel c'est du vrai
je pense que c'est ça dont il s'agit en
fait donc on peut peut-être mettre ces
aides là évidemment elles ont été hyper
importantes mais par ailleurs il y avait
tout un discours qui disait que la
culture était pas essentielle et les
saletés fermées
sans qu'on réfléchisse beaucoup
là-dessus donc il me semble que là
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
de plutôt s'interroger sur quel est la
politique de ce gouvernement en matière
de culture enfin comment il se situe par
rapport à un marché qui est qui est
intense qui est qui est violent qui est
dur l'arrivée des plateformes en France
je j'en sais quelque chose moi j'ai
travaillé pour Netflix parce que vous
travaillez pour nous en fait ça amène
aussi un monde où peut-être les rapports
de force bougent ou la concentration en
faveur de très gros groupe et en train
de se profiler du coup qu'est-ce que ça
entraîne en fait comme conséquence pour
les créateurs pour pour la variété en
fait des œuvres qui sont produites j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça qui est en
question aujourd'hui c'est comment le
gouvernement prend une place par rapport
au marché en fait parce que ça sert à ça
la politique le marché il va très bien
tout seul mais est-ce que la politique
elle peut faire contrepoids par endroits
pour essayer de faire en sorte que on
est une culture qui soit variée vivante
vigoureuse c'est un peu la réponse que
vous avez l'impression d'avoir reçu ou
pas reçu d'ailleurs de la part de du
gouvernement ou des pouvoirs publics le
marché enfin les sons de marché se
débrouiller après moi j'ai la conviction
que la culture c'est pas une marchandise
comme une autre
il me semble parfois que ce gouvernement
considère que beaucoup de choses sont
des marchandises alors qu'elles ne
devrait pas l'être et la culture la
santé l'éducation la justice c'est des
endroits où on doit avoir je vous crois
un regard particulier sur les choses et
oui effectivement il faut venir
peut-être contre le marché Rima
abdoulmala qui a quand même communiqué
sur la hausse du justement de du budget
de la culture 7% donc il y a quand même
un effort qui est fait et dans sa
réponse c'est vrai qui était un peu flou
parce que c'est des termes
technocratiques on comprend qu'il y a
une volonté politique pour privilégier
la souv du cinéma français donc ça il y
a quand même une volonté après
le cinéma on va y venir mais je voudrais
avant de d'ouvrir ce chapitre là savoir
s'il y a eu tout simplement une réponse
à l'appel à des états généraux du cinéma
français de la part du du gouvernement
oh là le plus beau yeux j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a pas eu
beaucoup
il y a pas de nouvelles mais juste pour
rebondir parce que je pensais à
l'intérieur à l'intervention de Nicole
Garcia à la radio aussi mais en fait il
y a aussi quelqu'un qui devrait être au
centre de toutes ces conversations c'est
le public
en fait parce que vous les avez
interrogé au début du reportage et tant
mieux je pense que le public les
spectateurs ils sont aussi acteurs de ce
sujet là et eux-mêmes peut-être mettrait
aussi de temps en temps l'église au
centre du village à la place à la place
de certaines personnes qui qui parlent
pour leur propre chapelle les gens qui
disent qu'il y a plus que le cinéma
populaire que Boxster qui qui marche
tous les 300 000 personnes qui sont
allés voir le film de rebeccase autowski
pourrait leur dire bah pas forcément
mais et l'inverse aussi mais donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi discuter avec les
gens qui qui qui
continuent à aller au cinéma et ceux qui
aimeraient y retourner que tout ça c'est
aussi un grand débat et que ça mettrait
aussi peut-être un petit peu d'ordre
dans ce que le gouvernement confonce
c'est-à-dire la marchandise culturelle
et la politique culturelle et c'est pas
la même chose évidemment mais en
préparant l'émission j'ai trouvé ces
chiffres qui sont quand même assez
vertigineux sur les succès de du cinéma
français entre 2015 et 2019 il y avait
plus de 50 films par an qui dépassaient
les 500 000 entrées et ces deux
dernières années c'est moins de 20 films
par an qui ont atteint ce seuil est-ce
que vous vous en êtes Philippe
Carcassonne à vous dire que nos
habitudes vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure je discutais de ça aussi avec
des directeurs de théâtre par exemple
qui sont confrontés pour beaucoup
d'entre eux à la même difficulté est-ce
que nos habitudes de passionnés ou de
consommateurs de culture ont
profondément radicalement changé
je pense que c'est un peu tôt pour le
dire et ce problème de calendrier il est
au centre du débat il y a des mutations
il y a effectivement des statistiques
inquiétantes pour répondre à la question
que vous souleviez tout à l'heure je
crois pas qu'il y ait de chiffre
officiels mais le chiffre qui circule en
sous-main sur la le non réabonnement au
carte illimitées ce serait de l'ordre de
30%. ce qui correspond à peu de choses
près à la chute la fréquentation donc
tout ça est au bout des tiques comme on
dit exactement
sauf que
la vraie la vraie remise en route des
salles si vous interrogez les
exploitants elle date de mars
la vraie remise en route de l'offre
cinéma on ne peut pas encore la
constater notamment sur les films
hollywoodiens à cause des arrêts de
tournage
on se plaint de nos chiffres à nous mais
enfin le le film Marvel qui est sorti
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième plus
mauvais démarrage de l'histoire de ce
studio sur les Avengers les Batman etc
au niveau ça vous parlez de chiffres
mondiaux non je parle de chiffre en
France mais vous avez raison de
interroger là-dessus est-ce que les
chiffres mondiaux sont pires
la France pardon c'est quoi ce film
c'est un film
et c'est l'un des c'est pas un mauvais
démarrage en soi ça fait 80 13000
entrées en France hier mais enfin oui
mais c'est un mauvais démarrage par
rapport aux habitudes de ce type de film
et effectivement
là où on pleure nos voisins eux sont
carrément au bord du suicide parce que
nos mauvais chiffres sont beaucoup moins
mauvais que les leurs et de ce point de
vue là si on veut donner raison à la
mise de la culture en dehors de son bel
effort pour le budget si on peut on peut
se glisser dans cet angle là maintenant
ce qu'on dit nous surtout c'est que
c'est très court c'est à dire mars
octobre on est encore un même année
l'offre de cinéma elle est pas encore
vraiment restructurée il y a un certain
nombre de gens qui ont été complètement
chamboulés dans leur processus de
création parfois même physiquement enfin
le covid c'est pas non plus juste une
des statistiques dans un journal il y a
des gens j'en connais pas mal dont nos
métiers de de fêtard et d'imprudent qui
ont qui ont qui ont qui ont payé un
certain prix n'arrive pas à retravailler
ou à créer comme créer des habitudes
qu'ils ont effectivement perdu il y a
pas que les spectateurs de cinéma qui
ont perdu tout le monde a perdu ses
habitudes et on s'est aperçu pendant ce
temps de confinement effectivement que
les plateformes nous permettaient quand
même de rester connectés nous donner
quelque chose à faire dans la journée
moi je vous avoue que j'ai plus regardé
Netflix ou
primes vidéo dans les les trois premiers
mois du confinement que dans les trois
ans précédant
mais ce qu'on dit c'est que c'est
peut-être un peu tôt pour décider que
comme vous le posez cette question là si
vous êtes un peu vite pour dire bon bah
nous avions changé fondamentalement
notre rapport à la culture et au cinéma
il est il sera plus jamais le même et ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut peut-être
être un peu accompagné plus sur le plan
réglementaire que sur le plan financier
le temps de voir comment on sort
vraiment de cette période
c'est un plan de relance c'est ça que
vous que vous espérez écoutez moi je
peux pas alors là pour le coup je peux
pas parler au nom d'un collectif qui a
des aspirations qui sont pas toutes
homogènes
ce qu'on là où on est tous d'accord
c'est dire il y a des questions qui se
posent et il y a une comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure une remise à plat
quand on en viendra aux mesures c'est un
peu trop tôt c'est trop tôt pour en
parler si on parle d'un plan de relance
on peut quand même dire que par exemple
les exploitants qui sont quand même en
première ligne aussi et ce que vous
parliez des pays où ça se passe pas bien
en Italie tous les il y a pratiquement
plus de cinéma donc comme ça voilà bon
donc les exploitantes pour que les
salles restent ouvertes il y a un geste
politique qui serait symbolique c'est
les aides sont à peu près les mêmes pour
tous les exploitants vous voyez du plus
petit au plus grand ce qui est ce qui
pendant le covid a été bien etc mais
maintenant peut-être qu'il faudrait
donner je sais pas moi 20% oui enfin
indexé à la fragilité du lieu c'est à
dire tous ces tous ces cinémas qui font
du ciné du cinéma d'auteur et ce n'est
pas péjoratif bon sang de bois
non mais qui font un travail incroyable
qui a envie de dessiner à chez eux qui
créent des débats qui essayent que leur
cinéma soit des lieux de vie on pourrait
les aider ne serait-ce qu'un tout petit
peu plus que les multiplexes qui de
toute façon eux programme des films qui
vont dans le sens du marché et qui
normalement ont moins de problèmes
ça ça pourrait être régulier assez
rapidement mais pendant une courte
période pour relancer la machine alors
effectivement si on parle de relance et
de mesure il y a la question de des
films qu'on est de quel type de cinéma
on parle je vous propose une réaction
c'est
à propos de cette exception française
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
Philippe Carcassonne c'est l'actrice on
va dire Belgo français puisqu'elle est
belge avant d'être française Virginie
Efira c'était lors de l'appel aux États
généraux du cinéma à l'intervenait en
visioconférence et finalement le
témoignait de son arrivée en France
quand je suis arrivé en France c'était
pas un voyage c'était pas un exotisme
fou mais quand même j'avais jamais vu
autant de salles de spectacle et de
salles de cinéma des petites des grandes
des cinémas d'art décès partout cette
possibilité de tout voir d'avoir accès à
tout aux divertissement populaire mais
aussi à des chemins de fiction plus
particuliers plus personnel parfois plus
audacieux plus risqué aussi plus
aventureux et c'est là que quelques
sauges jouent parce qu'il y a des films
qui
qui vous transforme évidemment les films
qui vous aident à avoir plus grand qui
vous aide à vivre
à comprendre avoir l'autre à espérer des
films qui vous choquent parfois aussi en
tout cas des films qui résistent à
l'uniformisation qui elle peut juste
vous aider à faire la sieste et donc
c'est très résistance allait une
formidation pour moi c'est une idée de
résistance française qui passe par la
culture par la diversité par la
pluralité de regard de perception de
goût et qui passe par un système de
financement qui n'a pas que la
rentabilité comme critère par un CNC
indépendant
le cinéma c'est ça c'est exactement ça
c'est la diversité et le public qui va
au cinéma c'est aussi la diversité et il
y en a qui vont au cinéma pour de
l'entertainment pour du diversesment
bien sûr et heureusement qu'il y a des
films qui sont faits pour ça la question
est pas de contester les gros fils à
gros budget etc mais il y a aussi des
gens qui vont et qui pourraient avoir
envie de retourner au cinéma pour des
expériences de vie pour des expériences
émotionnelles pour que ça change leur
vie
et bien voilà mais mais tous plus ou
moins ça évidemment et même ceux qui
pendant un moment là se sont mis à
regarder des plateformes je pense qu'ils
se sont mis à regarder des plateformes
en regardant d'un côté un petit movie un
peu pourri mais parce que juste avant de
dormir comme dirait et qui ont profité
de de films de patrimoine en que que de
programme là et qui moi je connais des
adolescents qui ont découvert François
Truffaut sur Netflix donc
rien n'est condamnable en soi la chose
elle est de réconcilier tous ces toutes
ces choses là en fait Fanny est-ce que
si on parle d'un plan ou d'une action
politique c'est ce qui nous réunit aussi
à la suite de ce de cet appel aux États
généraux est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que
c'est un risque pour vous c'est-à-dire
que l'action publique puisse aboutir à
cette universformisation pardon
qu'on souhaite ni les individus
ça peut être une action publique qui
favorise qui favorise
les blockbusters les gros studios les
conflits bien sûr c'est un risque et on
le voit bien je veux dire on le voit
dans la presse comment un moment lui le
fait que ça se concentre entre les mains
de quelques-uns c'est pas tellement bon
pour nous collectivement on s'en rend
compte on sait pas bon pour nos
démocraties en fait c'est pas bon pour
nous en tant qu'individus c'est pas bon
pour nous en tant que société donc pour
moi le risque il est là et encore une
fois je parle d'un endroit où moi-même
je grâce à Netflix 10% à voyager dans le
monde entier et c'est génial j'en suis
extrêmement heureuse et puis j'ai créé
une autre série qui s'appelle drôle fixe
aussi et en fait je sais moi créatrice
de série moi je travaille dans les
séries pas dans le cinéma ces
plateformes là elles nous font du bien à
nos créateurs d'un coup ça a créé un
appel d'air très très grand dans nos
pratiques on avait que cinq guichets en
France nous quand on écrit des séries
maintenant on en a 12 donc c'est une
certaine manière il y a une porosité les
talents aussi
ça par endroit ça nous fait du bien
aussi et ça crée une émulation et ça et
ça ça crée de la concurrence et ça nous
tire vers le haut mais à un moment ces
groupes là voilà si on parle de ça des
plateformes ou alors des grands groupes
même du cinéma c'est à dire que ça
concentre entre les mains de
quelques-uns trop de pouvoir et et c'est
bon pour personne c'est un peu pour moi
c'est un peu comme enfin par ailleurs je
vais aussi d'un milieu sportif mais la
métaphore que j'utilise parfois c'est un
peu comme si soudains on disait ben tous
les petits clubs là qui font de la
formation
ça fatigue en fait oh là là ces petits
villages là avec leur petit club de foot
nul on va pas les aider on va on va
aider que les gros centres de formation
des grosses villes non c'est absurde en
fait il faut absolument laisser émerger
des talents qui viennent voilà
d'endroits plus plus modestes plus
étroit mais qui finalement nourrissent
tout un écosystème et juste une question
oui est-ce que le public est assez grand
pour l'offre qui elle-même devient
protéiforme parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
moins d'offres avant il y avait moins de
cinéma il y avait moins de films il y
avait pas de plateforme et il y avait
quasiment enfin la démocratie
démographique française a pas
complètement explosé donc il y a ce
rapport-là aussi est-ce que il y a assez
de public pour cette offre là on a
peut-être assez si on respecte la
chronologie des médias ça tombe bien on
va en parler voilà voilà une une perche
que vous me tendez je propose à Jérémy
une semaine de nous rejoindre tout de
suite parce qu'on va parler Jérémy vous
le pouvez venir on va parler des des
plateformes on les a longuement évoqué
depuis le début de ce débat et ça va
nous amener à la chronologie des médias
mais d'abord quelques chiffres pour pour
parler des plateformes allez-y oui vous
allez le voir quelques chiffres
illustrent bien l'impact quand même du
streaming sur la baisse de fréquentation
des salles de cinéma et selon une étude
ifope publiée en mai dernier pendant le
Festival de Cannes et bien 55% des
Français déclarent être abonnés à une
plateforme de vidéo à la demande et
surtout 41% des abonnés à ces
plateformes affirme se rendre au moins
souvent souvent voire plus du tout au
cinéma la crise du covid a renforcé
cette montée en puissance des
plateformes 32% des sondés ont souscrit
à une offre de vidéo à la demande
pendant les périodes de fermeture des
salles aujourd'hui parmi ces plateformes
c'est Netflix qui rafle la mise en
France avec plus de 10 millions de
foyers abonnés en 2022 et le marché du
streaming va continuer de s'agrandir
avec l'arrivée de deux nouvelles
plateformes à la fin de l'année
Universal plus et Paramount plus et donc
on en parlait l'un des aspects de cette
concurrence c'est la chronologie des
médias oui tout à fait en fait cette
chronologie pour expliquer en fait elle
régit les dates auxquelles les films
peuvent être diffusés sur les
plateformes ou à la télévision dans les
mois qui suivent leur sortie au cinéma
en janvier dernier un nouvel accord est
signé avec les pouvoirs publics Canal+
par exemple peut diffuser les films six
mois après leur sortie en salle contre
huit mois auparavant six mois également
pour OCS 15 mois pour Netflix au lieu de
36 mois et 17 mois pour Disney plus les
prime vidéo c'est un accord assez
polémique dénoncé notamment par Disney
qui a fait pression en menaçant de
diffuser le film un gros budget Black
Panther 2 uniquement sur sa plateforme
de streaming et non dans les salles de
cinéma très dépendantes elles des
recettes justement des blockbusters
alors après plusieurs négociations le
film sortira bien sur grand écran en
novembre en échange d'une modification
de la chronologie des médias
certainement plus favorables aux
plateformes et c'est difficile de se
fâcher complètement avec ces plateformes
parce que on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
elle finance en partie le cinéma
français oui on l'a dit en fait depuis
2021 Netflix Disney Amazon Apple doivent
consacrer 20% de leur chiffre d'affaires
en France sur le financement de la
production d'oeuvre audiovisuelles et
cinématographique un engagement pris
avec le CSA et qui représente quand même
250 à 300 millions d'euros par an merci
beaucoup pour ces pour ces détails
guillemets audicino qu'est-ce qui se
joue avec ce bras de fer là sur la
chronologie des médias d'abord je
voudrais dire une petite chose je pense
que
je pense que Black Panther 2 si ils ont
ils finissent par le sortir en salle
c'est aussi parce qu'il faudrait juste
rappeler un petit truc c'est que le
cinéma en salle ça rapporte il faut
arrêter aussi de penser genre ça peut
rapporter énormément ils sont quand même
pas idiots ils font un bras de fer mais
ils savent que Black Panther 2 dans les
salles du monde entier je vais être
vulgaire mais ils vont se faire une un
max de thunes donc faut faut pas non
plus il le savent très bien ça et après
l'histoire de la chronologie des médias
c'est justement ça évidemment j'allais
vous dire même moi
si on me propose le même film le même
jour en salle et sur Netflix sur mon
canapé comment résister c'est difficile
bien sûr que c'est difficile donc il
faut préserver cette distance de
diffusion il faut même la réglementer à
mon iphone arrêter de descendre les
enfin là ça devient ridicule alors que
si de 12 mois et demi pour cela bientôt
ça va se compter en seconde enfin c'est
ridicule il faut réglementer et que et
après de toute façon les plateformes
elles ont besoin du cinéma pour se
composer de très beaux catalogues parce
que aujourd'hui quand vous remettez vous
vous mettez sur Netflix alors faut
beaucoup zapper aller dedans partout là
pas regarder le moteur de recherche qui
vous montre qui n'a jamais compris vos
goûts
mais bon et à la fin de la queue de la
liste là qui a tout d'un coup un film
d'auteur ou qu'on a envie de revoir ou
qu'on n'avait pas eu le temps de voir en
salle là oui mais à coule pas et voilà
chaque chaque beauté de cinéma à son
endroit et à ce moment
euh film Carcassonne voulait réagir sur
sur deux points qui se méritent d'être
un petit peu nuancé d'abord le
l'obligation d'investissement des
plateformes le chiffre qui est donné et
globalisé cineMay audiovisuel le cinéma
ne représente que 20 % d'accord de ce
montant et à l'intérieur de ces 20%, il
y a aussi ce qu'on appelle les achats
par opposition au pré-achat c'est-à-dire
les vieux films ou les films pas frais
en tous les cas donc l'injection
réelle d'argent de la part des deux
plateformes qui ont signé en
l'occurrence
Netflix et Amazon Prime vidéo
l'injection dans la nouvelle création
française elle est bonne en allant et
très avantageux bénéfique en
l'occurrence de l'ordre d'une trentaine
de millions c'est-à-dire ce que
c'est les autres essentiellement sur les
séries
et sur les et le secteur audiovisuel de
manière générale donc ça oui ça veut
dire rien des séries produites pour le
coup produit en France c'est ce que ça
on parle du cinéma et de la crise qui
traverse le cinéma c'est sûr que les
problèmes de salon moins concerné les
les séries est-ce qu'il n'a rien à voir
avec l'obligation que le gouvernement
avait donné à Canal+ à l'époque du
cinéma français là il balançait 30 % au
cinéma français à la création du cinéma
français et voilà donc ça n'a rien à
voir donc dans la production
cinématographique actuelle le poids des
plateformes est à peu près comparable
celui de CS donc c'est très loin
derrière Canal+ donc c'est très peu le
deuxième point que je souhaitais nuancer
c'est que notre jeune ami a dit que
Disney avait fini par sortir va sortir
effectivement Black Panther dans très
peu de semaines en échange d'une
modification de la colonie des médias
c'est pas exactement comme ça que ça se
présente
il y a eu une réunion le 4 octobre au
CNC avec tous les
parties concernées et Disney a considéré
ou fin de considérer que
une volonté suffisamment
collective s'est dégagé pour qu'on
réenvisage au moment de la clause de
revoyure qui est prévue dans le dans les
décrets en février prochain qu'on
réenvisage qu'on réexamine celles que
l'inédia ça veut pas dire qu'on va la
modifier et ça veut pas dire non plus
qu'on va la modifier dans leur sens ils
ont écrit un communiqué très rigolo tous
ces Disney c'est normal ils sont rigolo
sur le fait que tous les acteurs ou la
majorité des acteurs du secteur t'es
d'accord pour une cette chronologie soit
révisée complètement alors je sais pas
si les acteurs du secteur pour Disney
c'est c'est mini petite souris ou
l'oncle Picsou mais en tout cas ça n'est
pas des producteurs c'est pas
distributeurs c'est encore moins les
expériences ils ont pas entendu la même
chose que vous dans cette réunion c'est
ça
ils entendent rarement la belle chose je
voudrais qu'on parle des talents un peu
avec vous Fanny Hero sur on parlait de
porosité ça c'est ça c'est très bien
mais est-ce qu'il y a un risque que
c'est plateformes avec leur puissance de
feu leur puissance financière finissent
par siphonner les les talents et
notamment des talents qui qui rigolent
le cinéma d'auteur ou cette cette
variété du cinéma français ce qui est un
risque ben oui il y a un risque c'est
arrivé aux États-Unis
indépendant américain va pas très bien
pour toutes les raisons évoquées mais
aussi parce que ça me fait mise et voir
disparaît en fait
parce que effectivement les gens vont
travailler sur les plateformes et et
c'est vrai qu'en France moi ce que
j'observe c'est que on les plateformes
enfin dans les séries il y a aussi
toujours l'attractivité d'aller prendre
un réalisateur qui vient du cinéma parce
que il va bénéficier d'une image d'une
compétence d'une expérience
et nous français on sait ce que ça
suppose d'arriver à être un réalisateur
reconnu ça veut dire avoir fait un film
de films trois films et peut-être que
ces premiers films là ils ont pas
forcément bien marché jusqu'à ce qu'il y
en ait un qui a marché et là on est
repéré et puis alors du coup on peut on
peut passer sur une plateforme mais du
coup c'est pour ça aussi pour dire qu'il
y a une transversalité c'est que le
système qui a permis à ses réalisateur
là d'émerger le système qui a permis à
un des techniciens d'être compétent en
fait d'avoir une compétence incroyable
en France on a une compétence incroyable
pour fabriquer nos films ce serait
extrêmement dommage que ce vivier là
n'aille que sur les plateformes et ne
puisse plus continuer d'exister personne
n'en parle mais c'est quand même pas du
tout la même expérience de regarder un
film aussi grand soit-il dans son canapé
que dans une salle de cinéma enfin il y
a ça aussi quand on parlait de
communication de campagne de
communication il faut expliquer ça aux
gens quand même on peut à la fois
regarder Netflix et aller au cinéma mais
pour moi ça n'a rien à voir c'est
absolument différent c'est comme écouter
ouvrir un livre ou l'écouter de façon
Nar sur un podcast enfin ça veut dire ça
n'a rien à voir ce sont des expériences
de vie qui sont totalement différentes
et je pense que peut-être axé et de
redonner du désir justement au public ça
peut être aussi une piste ah ben
clairement avec des films
c'est la coïncidence émerveilleuse mais
Virginie Efira
quand vous voyez à la fiche de quoi en
ce moment de deux films qu'on peut
estimer être des films d'auteurs
revoir Paris et les enfants des autres
de rebeccafki enfin et Alice vinocourt
pour oeuvre Paris et en même temps cette
actrice elle elle est une chair que le
public
français reconnaît comme sienne il y a
quelque chose qui se passe c'est une
chaire désirable le public a envie
d'aller voir les aventures de Virginie
Efira au cinéma où les aventures de
rochedysem donc le désir il est possible
et après mais c'est vrai qu'il faut que
les acteurs et les techniciens soient
dispo parce que en plus du Vivier qui
qui peut être happée par le vivier de
talent c'est aussi la disponibilité il y
a des fois vous avez des cinéases qui
veulent tourner avec certains acteurs ou
certains actrices ou avoir un chef
opérateur précis ou un technicien précis
et ben ils ne peuvent pas parce que
cette personne est prise et réservée et
mise sous clés pendant 6 mois par une
série alors je voudrais une plateforme
c'est je voulais juste vous clichéo qui
me paraît très juste sur le fait que le
vivier des séries vient du cinéma et et
rappeler qu'il y a aucune nécessité
d'opposer la pratique de la série à
celle du cinéma
qu'il convient par contre donc nous on a
on a aucune démarche de stylité à
l'égard des plateformes on a en revanche
une méfiance à l'égard des des
conséquences qu'une certaine
compétitivité entre ces mêmes
plateformes entraîne ne serait-ce qu'en
termes de calendrier moi j'ai eu la
curiosité par exemple j'ai comme
beaucoup de gens comme énormément de
gens dans le monde j'ai regardé et
énormément aimé de Squid game une série
Netflix pas en anglais qui est le plus
gros succès d'une série non anglophones
bon every coréenne
et j'ai trouvé ça formidable et j'ai dit
bravo Netflix je vais m'arrêter de d'en
dire du mal parce que s'ils font une
chose comme ça c'est vraiment formidable
puis je suis quand même aller un petit
peu fouiller et j'ai vu que alors je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup de monimies en
Corée maintenant le clan je crois que
c'est pas le cas il se trouve que le
scénariste il est tout seul il s'appelle
Monsieur Wang le réalisateur il est tout
seul il s'appelle Monsieur Wang le
producteur il est tout seul il s'appelle
Monsieur Wang et le showrunner il est
tout seul aussi il s'appelle Monsieur
Wang donc c'est l'oeuvre d'un seul homme
simplement il a mis 6 ans
alors si aujourd'hui je vous pratiquais
plus les plateformes que moi mais si
aujourd'hui on vous passe commande chez
l'une de ces plateformes et vous dites
oui d'accord ça m'intéresse mais
rendez-vous dans 6 ans je suis pas sûr
que ça que ça fasse le la blague Fanny
si on compare un peu l'économie des deux
des deux systèmes ou du cinéma et des
plateformes c'est quoi la principale
différence parce que c'est intéressant
sur 10% la première saison c'est
français et à partir de la saison 2 il y
a Netflix qui rentre dans la danse oui
bah ça ça arrive parfois on peut être
sur une chaîne et puis avoir une
deuxième fenêtre comme on dit et là en
l'occurrence bah depuis l'arrivée de
Netflix ça se produit
la principale différence
une série est financée à 90% par le
diffuseur donc en fait c'est vraiment un
lien étroit entre nous l'équipe de
création les producteurs les auteurs et
le diffuseur donc la chaîne ou le
plateforme et du coup le diffuseur est
assez puissant en fait c'est à dire
qu'il peut aussi intervenir nous faire
donc nous par exemple scénariste de télé
on est rompu à l'exercice de recevoir
des notes on a hyper l'habitude de ça on
sait qu'on peut poser avec ça au cinéma
pour financer un film il faut vous le
savez mieux que moi
il faut s'adresser à 8 10 12 guichets en
fait qui vont être publics privés enfin
toutes sortes de de façon de financer un
film et qui font à la fin en fait ce
qu'il va faire Derrer tous ces gens
c'est la vision d'un créateur en fait
enfin la vision quand même d'un
réalisateur et accompagné d'une équipe
artistique et donc ça ça crée quand même
une différence c'est vrai ce qui fait
pencher des séries du côté de quelque
chose d'un peu plus industriel même si
moi j'aime à défendre l'idée que dans
les séries aussi il y a de la vision
d'auteurs et que les séries d'ailleurs
on met dans un gros panier en fait les
séries ça veut un peu rien dire il y a
toutes sortes de séries d'ailleurs comme
il y a aussi toutes sortes de
plateformes elles ont pas toutes la même
ligne enfin quand elles ont une ligne
parce que des fois on se perd
pas toujours très clair mais en gros
voilà ça il faut faire attention à pas
non plus tout mettre stigmatiser mettre
tout dans le panier bien sûr merci
beaucoup c'est trop vite mais un grand
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat aller au cinéma évidemment je ne
peux pas terminer cette émission sans
vous donner l'injonction d'aller au
cinéma dès ce soir des ce week-end
profitez-en il y a de très bons films et
notamment le film les enfants des autres
de avec Virginie Efira qui est un petit
bijou voilà merci à tous d'avoir
participé à cette émission demain un
rendez-vous sur notre antenne
rendez-vous politique dans la matinale
on vient de Monsigny reçoit Vladimir
c'est le Rossi diplomate et écrivain
russe belle soirée à toutes et à tous
salut
[Musique]